hey buddy it's Mike from Immortals and
welcome to today's video you know today
is October 13th 2022 and the CPI number
came out today was came in hotter than
expected you know it Rose uh 0.4 which
is basically double Market expectations
um you know year on Year we're still
high at 8.2 and
um you know the core CPI at 6.6 is the
most has been since 1982 and the market
did what it's supposed to do it got
slammed however afterwards the market
rallied and you know let's take a let's
take a look at what happened at the
numbers so this is um you know this is
the e-mini chart uh yesterday and we're
just sort of humming Along coming along
and then bam you know the number comes
out we drop
um you know basically over 100 points
and you know what was interesting in
this uh drop is obviously there's no
liquidity
initially right it took a long time for
the market to find you know some
liquidity basically I mean when you look
at it
from
36 13 and three quarters
all the way down
to
35.73 and a quarter there was no trades
nothing all the liquidity got pulled you
know the CPI number is
probably I don't know we could argue
back and forth about the non-farm
payroll and the CPI number but it's the
number that you know Traders are are
really watching uh very closely to see
what's happening you know with the
economy and
it's one of those numbers that you don't
want to be participating in you know I
saw some people posting some charts and
stuff oh yeah you know they're talking
about what's happening right before the
number gets released you know what
position they would take no you know
professional Traders that's why there's
no liquidity here the professional money
is out all right they're not sitting
here trying to play the number unless
they got some sort of inside information
or you know some of these hedge funds
hire people from
um the government that you know used to
work on these numbers to sort of
construct the number themselves but
this lack of liquidity here is is very
uh glaring and very telling you know
that's a 40-point area where there was
no no liquidity finally you know it hit
some resting bits in here that have been
in here for a while at 70
um two and three quarters 69 you know on
down to you know 57 and
I even saw a post of a person that says
well yeah you know the market dropped
because it was it happened in the
pre-market yeah the market dropped not
because it was in the pre-market because
you know his argument was there's lack
of liquidity well yeah because people
aren't participating in it everyone's
waiting for this number right all eyes
around the U.S you know the professional
trading desks you know the banks the
hedge funds they're waiting for this
number to come out
and in a way this Market's been recently
in the last several months this is like
I'll say the World Series or you know
the Super Bowl numbers but um you know
it's highly anticipated I guess is is
the term that I'm looking for and it
didn't disappoint in terms of Market uh
reaction right I mean we had over a
hundred Point drop within a couple of
minutes you know we got down
um you know 35 10 right here and a
quarter and then we bounced up now you
know I've always told people you know
everyone they're all excited about
trading the numbers no you don't want to
be involved around a number because if
you get it wrong you're going to get
bent over and you know something stuck
up your body you probably don't want so
let the number play out I know for
many Traders they let the number come
out let the market digest it you know
all the the retail money everybody
that's you know stopped out of the
market Etc you know once they're all
stopped out you know the Market's going
to find some sort of balance again and
you know usually
five minutes 15 minutes is is enough
time because you can see how this Market
is reacting okay you're getting bars you
know basically we'll call this one 35 12
all the way up to 35 uh you know 31 so
almost a 20 point bar and this is a 30
second chart it's not a one minute chart
it's not a five minute chart it's a 30
second chart you have to understand it
when you have these big numbers coming
out there will be volatility
it's not like looking at it after the
fact oh yeah there's a lot of volatility
in the market no when you have a big
announcement a big number coming out CPI
non-farm payrolls obviously a Fed
announcement there will be volatility
that ensues I mean you don't have to
guess you know is there or isn't you
have to expect it you have to expect
that there's going to be volatility
you're going to have these wide-ranging
bars let the market settle down it took
about five minutes to sort of settle
down actually more like 10 minutes where
you're sort of getting back to sort of
normal you know three four point bars
and the best advice I give is just wait
till the cash opened at 8 30 if you're
going to start trading and once the cash
opened today
we came in we started selling off we put
in this new low at uh O2 okay we have a
Divergence we got some positive Deltas
coming in down there you know Delta
Divergence being a new or equal low
with positive Delta
and the market rallied from O2
basically up to 20. that it just sort of
you know we had a level up in here from
earlier acting as resistance after it
popped up some aggressive selling came
back in you sort of went back Sideways
from 35 808 up to 13 14 but in this area
where we're going sideways there was a
lot of bullish order flow coming in you
can see here
you know we got multiple bind imbalances
in the one bar we got a very strong
Delta 1600 and it's closing sort of on
its Max Delta number our Delta number
was 16 17. our Max Delta was 16 18. so
we're closing right on it basically
which is a sign of a very strong
aggressive buying now that doesn't mean
that there was no aggressive selling in
the bar Max Delta means is how strong
the positive Delta was in the bar okay
and we got you know these two blue bars
this is our our you know very bullish
um value areas coming in here so as this
Market is sort of going sideways we're
seeing
um value being formed
right because we found a balance area
and and when you're in Balance right
you're forming value and based off of
what you're seeing in
um the value it's becoming bullish in
here like these two blue bars
is bullish value areas obviously the
aggressive buying in this bar we do pop
up to sort of this new swing high up to
uh you know 23 come off again and then
we start seeing that aggressive buying
step right back in
you've seen a stack binding balance here
stack buying a balance here
obviously another bullish value being
formed right here we have a inverse
imbalance so what do we have happening
here okay we're you know our low is O2
we're trading around you know 14 15 in
here you know all the way up into 20 but
we're seeing very strong buying coming
in
all right we've seen stack buying a
balance in this bar followed by another
bar with stack buying and balance
followed by another bar with an inverse
imbalance which is a sign of trap
Traders and absorption taking place and
sort of to open this bar up a little bit
more
I've talked about this before
what do we have at the top of this bar
right well the point of control is up
near the top but more importantly sort
of our heaviest volume is taking place
here the 474
all right 474 is your biggest volume in
this bar right at the 14 and three
quarters it's the biggest volume in the
previous bar in the previous bar in the
previous bar so what happened mark it
sold off now we're getting the
aggressive buyers coming in now we're
getting not only the aggressive buyers
coming in to take the market higher but
now we have a strong passive buyer to
absorb whatever selling is coming in
here so they're absorbing you know you
can see it's the imbalance 474 against
16. we got you know 309 against 259 now
that's not an imbalance but again 309 is
a heavy volume as well
and then in the next bar more aggressive
buying comes in just above those levels
and we're starting to go higher right
that's what you want to see right you
don't want to just see aggressive buying
taking place you want to see after that
aggressive buying what you want to see
is the market go bid over you want to
see it get bid at that price level to
indicate that yeah not only do we have
aggressive buying taking the market up
but we have strong passive buying
supporting the market from dropping
further
and the market starts marching up it was
a very dramatic quick rise you know
there was really wasn't much bearish
information in here
um you know coming in you know even this
bar people say we got this big negative
Delta minus 677. yeah that's a big
strong negative Delta but the bar is a
green candle look at why it's negative
677s because look at this volume this
big bid came in here you know traded
1038 here on the bid it's a thousand
on the bid here at 31 and a quarter to
support this market right just as we saw
earlier here this 474 is supporting this
Market
okay and you see the market you can just
draw these lines in here right just draw
the F6 here okay I know that around the
31 31 and a quarter
there's support right it does dip back
into it in the next bar and a couple
bars later but it's not really breaking
down
okay so I know you know when I see that
big volume just stick out like that it's
so obvious that there's support in this
market the trade you know you want to be
taking is is to the upside right and
then it pops Boom Big Wide Bar big you
know big volatility 33 low up to 43 High
you know a 10 point bar again this is a
30 second chart right it's not a five
minute chart you're getting you know 10
point bars really quick
so again from the 31 31 and a quarter
area trades all the way up into the 40s
right within two or three minutes
okay the market sort of pulled back
again this 31 area right we had that big
volume
what do you think well that's probably
going to be a support area right because
I know I had big buyers down in here
when it comes back here you know you
want to be asking are they still there
is the support being held
and you know we get within a point of it
32 and a quarter and then we sort of
rally back up again again quite strongly
bullish value area being formed here as
this Market was going sideways
rally up you know more aggressive buying
taking place here you got one two three
four buying imbalances that's why
there's this green bar around here you
know out of nowhere right we're just
sort of putting in here you know it
looks like we're just sort of rotating
here this is your first sign of
aggressive buying this is what our
software will do is it'll highlight
These Bars where you have those spread
out buying imbalances right then the
next bar has got the Stacked buying
imbalance
you know people ask me which is more
important a stack buying a balance or
multiple imbalances well in my opinion
multiple imbalances is probably a little
bit stronger than stack bind imbalances
simply because it can come in
before the stack mind about so if you're
waiting for a stack binding balance to
come in comes in here around 44 but if
you're watching this bar
before the stack buying a balance you're
seeing those multiple binding balances
come in right and then again you know we
pop all the way back up into the 60s
where we hit a level from earlier
at 56 we do bounce back down to where
the area where you had the aggressive
buying taking place right where that
stack buying a balance was and the
market just bounces back up and this is
all just you know it's this is at nine
in the morning already you know we've
only been open since the cash for about
45 minutes
you know this is what 9 10 here is 9 15.
so this would be about 45 minutes
already you're getting a lot of action
you know people talk about volatility
you have to expect those days when
there's going to be a lot of volatility
in the market and like I said when you
have a big number coming out that
everyone's watching CPI is one of them
non-farm payrolls you're going to expect
volatility you're going to you know
you're gonna expect that if you're
trading by the end of the day you're
going to feel like you've been you know
in a wrestling match basically you're
gonna you're gonna feel exhausted and to
be honest the way this Market was moving
you know it was very reminiscent of you
know
I don't want to say 2020 you know when
covet hit but you know more reminiscent
of
the financial crisis where you get these
big pushes down and the big pushes back
up you know big swings and it's just
sort of coming in in waves and waves one
after the other
um but uh anyway you know we pull back
again you had the bearish value area
coming in here but then we just went
sideways it didn't really sell off okay
so when you get something that's you
know the market is starting to sell off
you get something bearish you got the
bearish value here and then the market
just goes sideways if it's not breaking
what do you do
you don't sit here and get short and
wait and sit in Hope
well you got the bearish information in
this bar next bar is inside inside
inside inside
right when you have bars that are inside
for an extended period of time and this
one in this case it's one two three four
five six bars which is quite a lot
yeah anything over threes inside bars is
a lot
wait for the breakouts and it comes
right as you're breaking out here you
got to stack buying and balance okay
what's that telling you the trade is to
the upside
all right and you see it it moves you
know but again from 47 just up into the
53 so it's not one of these 10 point
moves but you have that breakout coming
in right here now I do know that I had
this area here 44 uh you know we'll call
it 45 right here just outside that down
to 43 and a half
that if the market comes back down okay
I mean
sort of that's an area that I'd be
looking for the aggressive buying to
come in
it didn't really come it came in there
and you know even though it's breaking
through it's kind of holding um if
you're along off of this stack buying
and balance
um you know you run into some bearish
information here and obviously you have
to stack buying and balance here but
it's followed with another stack selling
the balance right afterwards which is a
bearish sign you know if you're getting
short you can you'd be looking for some
support in here and it just sort of goes
sideways you can see these point of
controls just lining up one after the
other finally it looks like it's going
to break then it just has you know a
volatile Market does
just as it looks like it's breaking down
it reverses back up
all right now again you know what was
interesting is you know which something
you see a lot on volatile markets are
the back and forth
imbalances right you got two stack
buying imbalances followed by a borrow
stack selling a balance followed by a
bar with stack buying imbalance
right and it's frustrating let's say the
least when you when you're seeing that
and again these aren't big imbalances
per se you know the volumes involved in
seven against 41 zero against ten seven
against 36 here's uh zero against 18
zero against fourteen zero against uh 39
so that's not like you know something
against 180 or 140 390 it's kind of thin
volumes but you know that's to be
expected on a market that's exhibiting
some volatility now you know in the next
video I'll talk a bit more about what
this level is here this is what we call
Market weakness
um you know there was
um you know again this was Market
weakness taking place here
but again you know it's interesting
because this market right if you are
using the order flows Trader software
um you know you got a bullish Prominent
Point of control here here you've got
bullish value area forming
um you know right before the market
pops back up um you know basically from
60 almost up to 70 got up to like 68 but
it was a nice move up here
um you know just trading these value
areas right these bullish and bearish
value areas here's a bearish one
um obviously got that stack selling and
balance
coming inside there and just look how
the market sells off comes right back up
to that stack selling a balance where
you had the aggressive trading taking
place and starts coming off a little bit
before you get the aggressive buying
coming in but again you know on a market
that has volatility
it doesn't take much to cause
a stacked imbalance
okay and that's why you're going to see
more on days that are more volatile just
as you know on markets that exhibit more
volatility like say mini NASDAQ mnq or
even NQ you're going to see these a lot
more imbalances than you would in as
opposed to seeing it in the e-minis okay
this purple line case you're wondering
that's Market
um strength taking place there but again
I'll talk about Market strength Market
weakness in
in a different video but really what I
want to cover today is just you know the
the crazy price action when you can see
right even one all the way up to 75
um came back down back up again I mean
it was just a a real roller coaster of
events and you know honestly I could
talk about the rest of the day but this
video would probably go on for about two
hours there's just a lot of information
but you know really what I want to talk
about as I did was you know what to look
for on days where you're expecting High
volatility in the markets okay and again
it's not one of these things where you
look after the fact and say oh yeah that
market had it had high volatility no you
got to know right being part of being a
Trader is understanding days that can
exhibit High volatility now I wasn't
expecting this Market to have such a
violent swing down followed by an even
stronger swing back up like we had today
you know two percent down five percent
up but
you know from the lows but it's just one
of those things where you have to come
in being ready right have sort of a plan
of action say yeah you know what today
is going to be a volatile today and I'm
going to have to be quick in my
analysis I'm going to be quick in my uh
pulling the trigger on the trades
basically right because you know what
you don't want to be doing is caught you
know
lollygagging you know eating a Popsicle
or ice cream cone while the Market's
going nuts Okay so
if you enjoyed this video you'll end it
there if you enjoyed this video be sure
to like subscribe you know it makes me
feel good that people are liking the
videos and subscribing to the channel
that's why I put out this content for
you so thanks everyone and I'll see you
guys on the next video